[Music]
hi I'm Anna Roth from the Microsoft
cognitive services computer vision team
and today I'm here talking about our
custom vision service so the custom
vision service which is available at
custom vision AI is a service for
helping people build their own custom
image classifiers so you recognize
objects or things that they care about
in this example I have built a
classifier to recognize plants that are
available at the Japanese garden in
Seattle I wanna be able to recognize
things like a Japanese pine a cypress or
a Japanese maple the way that you do
this is that you upload some example
images save maybe 50 images per class
and then all you have to do is hit train
and you have a classifier that's hosted
for you at an API and an HTTP endpoint
so I've already built my classifier and
trained it I have it right here
and now I'm gonna run a quick test to
see if it's working so I'm doing a quick
test here and I'll just grab an image
that I took earlier that I have from
earlier it's a picture of a Japanese
maple let's see if we get this right so
I've uploaded the image here and then
with very very high confidence it turns
out that my classifier pretty good that
predicted that it's a Japanese maple the
other neat thing about this system is
that every image that you send for
classification is saved so all these
images that I submitted previously have
been saved here I can actually go label
them and then over time improve my
classifier so the custom vision service
is a really really easy way for anybody
to build a classifier in a couple of
minutes and improve it over time I hope
you'll give it a chance to try it out
and you can do so by going to custom
vision dot ai that's custom vision AI
and give it a shot today thank you